boom
a loud and very public end to a story
the American people watched unfold for
days a high altitude balloon crossing
the country which the US military said
was China's attempt to spy on the U.S it
was shot down Saturday when an F-22
fighter jet launched a single missile
the balloon and Equipment plunging into
the Atlantic Ocean now as the U.S Navy
Works to retrieve the debris a growing
criticism in Washington that the balloon
got that far the president was paralyzed
for an entire week by a balloon we
should have shot this balloon down over
the Aleutian Islands we should never
have allowed it to Transit the entire
continental United States it doesn't
seem like the president knew about the
balloon then according to Pentagon
officials it was first picked up off the
coast of Alaska on Saturday January 28th
transiting through Canada and then
entering through northern Idaho and onto
Montana on the 28th the following
Tuesday that was the day that the White
House says President Joe Biden was first
informed he gave the order to shoot it
down Wednesday the military says it
wasn't safe to do it over land so they
waited until it reached the coast we
sent a clear message to China that this
is not acceptable
we protected civilians
we gained more intelligence while
protecting our own sensitive information
we believe this week the gang of eight
is going to be briefed on The Incident
That's the leadership of the
intelligence committees and of the house
and the Senate both Democrats and
Republicans the following week on
February 15th we believe the entire
Senate is going to get a classified
briefing meaning this controversy and
these criticisms are unlikely to end
anytime soon
Patty Calhoun Al Jazeera Washington